today's video is kindly sponsored by
policy genius hey 42 here imagine this
you wake up one morning to discover
you've run out of coffee that alone
might sound like a plot for a horror
story but things are about to get worse
you start walking to the corner shop to
stock up on your muka java when you
notice the world around you is in total
chaos
cars are crashed into buildings and each
other broken electricity ysp sparks in
all directions people are wandering
aimlessly around the streets wailing at
the top of their lungs
you try to help an old lady nearby and
discover she's blind you try to help
another person and realize he's blind
too
in fact everyone around you has gone
blind overnight
as if that wasn't enough you soon learn
you're sharing the world with seven foot
tall carnivorous plants intent on
extermination of the human race
with deadly stingers the ability to walk
and the power to make decisions
and communicate with each other they
seem like a very human enemy it's not
long before the plants are dominating
the planet and humanity is on the brink
of extinction
you haven't felt this kind of hopeless
since waking up on a monday after a four
day techno festival though i'd love to
claim this story as the product of my
own fertile imagination it actually
belongs to author john windham who wrote
the day of the triffids triffids the
murderous semi-sentient plants in
wyndham's novel may have seemed like a
far-fetched fantasy when he published
his book in the early 1950s
but the idea of conscious plants wasn't
totally new
as far back as ancient greece trees were
said to deliver prophecies whilst in the
late 1800s darwin suggested that plants
may have some sort of intelligence with
their root tips acting in a similar way
to the brain of lower animals in the
1970s a sensational book called the
secret life of plants claimed to show
scientific evidence for the existence of
plant consciousness including plant
emotions
when the book got panned by the
scientific community for being
pseudoscience
research in the area largely died away
but in the last 20 years or so
it's resurfaced according to some of the
latest findings
plants may have intentions feelings
and even something we might tentatively
call
consciousness
life insurance gives you peace of mind
that if something happens to you your
loved ones would have a financial
cushion to pay for things like rent or
mortgage payments loans education costs
and everyday expenses so policy genius
makes it easy to compare quotes from
over a dozen top insurers all in one
place meaning you could save 50 percent
or more on life insurance by comparing
quotes with policy genius and that's
because the licensed experts at policy
genius work for you not the insurance
companies so you can trust them to help
you navigate every step of the shopping
and buying process that kind of service
has earned policy genius thousands of
five-star reviews across trustpilot and
google
so how does it work well first you need
to head over to www.policy.js
forward slash 42
and answer a few questions about
yourself
then in minutes you can work out how
much life insurance coverage you
actually need and compare personalized
quotes to find your best price
then when you're ready to apply the
policy genius licensed experts will help
you understand your options and apply
for a policy head to
www.policygenius.comforwardslash42 to
get your free life insurance quotes and
see how much you could save
many of the scientists exploring these
theories are connected to the rather new
and still very controversial field of
plant neurobiology this field aims to
understand how plants process
environmental information in order to
grow flourish and reproduce
it also studies how communication occurs
within the plant itself between one part
of the plant and another and how plants
communicate with each other these
communication systems may provide the
basis for abilities like cognition
learning and consciousness
i know for some of you it might feel as
though someone's attaching a car battery
to your nipples every time i apply the
word consciousness to plants
there's no doubt it's a shocking idea
and the subject is certainly pretty
controversial we still don't have a
particularly good handle on what our own
version of consciousness is so
attempting to apply that term to other
animals let alone plants
is always going to be tricky
definitions as to what exactly
consciousness is in the first place vary
wildly depending on whether you're
talking to a philosopher a cognitive
neuroscientist an atheist a buddhist or
that guy in town who talks to lampposts
but for the purposes of this video let's
just go with the dictionary definition
that consciousness is the state of being
aware of internal and external phenomena
with the potential to experience
thoughts and emotions
and make decisions
traditionally it's been assumed that
consciousness is only really possible
where there's some sort of brain and
nervous system involved
but plants don't work that way
if plants had a centralized control
center like our brain
then any grazing animal or head trimmer
could come along and suddenly lop it off
for this reason alone it makes
evolutionary sense that plant
consciousness
if it does indeed exist would be
decentralized up to 90 percent of
certain plant root systems can be
removed and they're still able to
regenerate
this idea of a distributed control
center is part of the reason why
darwin was quite literally on point with
his thinking here
every root tip has a tiny part
responsible for conducting electrical
signals
the same type of signals found in human
neurons
each one of those root tips can
continuously detect and monitor various
physical parameters of the soil around
it and at least 15 different chemicals
but where does all that data go recent
studies suggest that information moves
through plants in a surprisingly
familiar way animal nerve cells
communicate with each other using an
amino acid called glutamate once this
substance is released by a stimulated
nerve cell it sets off a chain reaction
in nearby cells in the form of a wave of
calcium ions this process continues from
cell to cell and allows for the kind of
long-distance internal communication
that tells your brain your nipples are
attached to a car battery again
plants don't have nerve cells as such
but their cells are also able to
communicate with one another using
calcium and glutamate
something that's been shown
experimentally in mustard plants
where damage to leaves send signals to
other leaves
whether this is some kind of an internal
warning system a pain signal or
something else entirely we aren't quite
sure so it seems internal plant
communication functions in a very
similar way to that of animals but what
about external communication
is that even a thing in plants
we all know plants are masters of
attracting insects using the sweet smell
of nectar the scent is a timeless
classic in the insect world a bit like
old spice in the 70s but it turns out
plants also use electric fields to
communicate with pollinators
releasing targeted bursts of scent when
they detect for example the electrical
field of a nearby bee
if plants are chatting with insects can
we assume they're also communicating
with other plants
well let's start with the obvious bit
plants don't have mouths or vocal cords
to form sound and words
and simply shaking their leaves is
hardly an effective mode of
communication as anyone who's ever worn
a shell suit will tell you rustling is
very difficult to control
in the early 80s two studies were
published theorizing that sugar maples
poplars and willow trees were able to
warn one another of insect attacks
the experiments found that trees near
those infested with pests started to
produce large amounts of insect
repelling chemicals to thwart the
attacks before they could begin
it seems those trees somehow knew their
neighbours were under siege and started
arming their metaphorical battlements
even though the enemy hadn't actually
arrived yet the papers were dismissed at
the time
but further research has revealed they
were actually onto something it's now an
accepted fact that when plants are eaten
they release chemical distress flares in
the form of volatile organic compounds
and that nearby plants detect those
signals and respond accordingly
there's no denying that's communication
of a sort
and it proves plants do more than just
passively exist
they react to a changing environment
which could be interpreted as an
indication of consciousness
but the real question we have to ask is
is this communication intentional or
just an automated involuntary release of
chemicals that's evolved as a simple
darwinian survival mechanism
well like my ex-girlfriend said when i
caught her looking at nude pictures of
papa smurf it's complicated
scientists are only just starting to
learn how to decode the signals that
plants emit
but one recent study of sagebrushes
noted that airborne communication using
volatile compounds was more effective
amongst plants that were more closely
genetically related versus plants that
weren't
some scientists believe this suggests
plants are looking out for their own so
to speak if you think the idea that
plants believe their sap is thicker than
water is just scientists erroneously
assigning plants human qualities then
you're not alone but more on that later
if you've watched my video about the
magic mushroom that will save humanity
you'll know there's more to plants
communication than just whispers on the
wind
what's going on in the earth itself is
even more complex using root systems and
subterranean fungal networks trees are
able to communicate with one another and
even send water and nutrients to other
trees in need
these include their own offspring
saplings not yet tall enough to reach
the sunlight necessary for
photosynthesis it's a bit like leaving
home as a teenager but still getting
lasagna from your mum because she's
worried you're not eating well
amazingly some stumps of trees fell
hundreds of years ago are still alive
today thanks to the nutrients they
receive via this underground network
the relationship between fungi and trees
is estimated to be around 450 million
years old and 90 of trees are said to
take advantage of it messages are
composed of hormones chemicals and even
electrical pulses with the most popular
topics of underground plant-based
conversation related to things like
disease and drought
so
it seems plants can respond to their
environment and communicate
possible signs of consciousness
taking things a step further how about
intelligence or even memory
one rather clever if somewhat brutal
experiment using mimosas appears to show
that plants have both memory and the
ability to learn mimosa plants are
famous for curling up their leaves when
disturbed so as part of the test potted
mimosas were dropped from a few inches
above the ground the first time the four
was enough to cause all the plants to
close their leaves as expected
but
from the second and third drops some of
the plants were no longer reacting
after having been dropped in this way
dozens of times
none of the mimosas were retracting
their leaves anymore just like humans
and other animals eventually filter out
stimuli that isn't important it seems
the mimosas had decided a small drop was
nothing to worry about the skeptics
suggested the plants were simply tired
from being dropped onto solid ground
over and over again a reasonable
observation if you ask me
but when the experiment was repeated
with the same plants a week
and then a month later
they reacted in exactly the same way
they didn't curl up their leaves in
response to being dropped
meaning mimosa plants are not only able
to recognize the difference between an
apparent threat and a real one they can
remember that difference for at least a
month
by way of contrast honeybees who are
able to memorize locations are seen as a
model animal for studying learning and
memory but
they only have a long-term memory of up
to nine days
emerging studies on plants seem to show
the possibility
of intention intelligence memory and
learning
all elements of what people would
typically call
consciousness
but many mainstream scientists think the
field of plant neurobiology is a pile of
compost one group of 32 experts recently
published an attack on the idea that
plants possess intelligence declaring
everything can be explained by natural
selection they say humans are incurably
inclined to believe in the myth of
thinking feeling and sentient trees
i'm looking at you tolkien and that the
research has been anthropomorphized
that is everything has been interpreted
in terms of human characteristics
which in reality
simply don't apply to plants
given the fact that new discoveries are
happening all the time and there's so
much we don't yet understand about
plants it looks like it will still be
some time before we know for sure
whether or not
our gardens are conscious
of course unless you're a vegan who's
paranoid about being resigned to a diet
of soil for the rest of your life that
might not matter very much to you
but i for one will be keeping an eye on
those leafy bastards
just in case thanks for watching